You've been betrayed by someone.
And so you fall into that underworld of,
of,
of doubt about everything.
And it's a serious place
to be in that underworld a,
because not only do you not know where
you came from or who you are or where
you're going,
that's bad enough.
So that's the underworld itself.
But there's a subdivision
of the underworld,
like the worst suburb,
which is I think what hell is essentially
from a metaphysical perspective
because you know,
if someone really cuts
you off at the knees,
especially if they do
it in a malevolent way,
and if you're going to be betrayed
and you really want to be,
be trade properly,
you want to be betrayed by someone
who's really out to hurt you.
You know,
they just weren't being stupid.
They were like after
you for whatever reason.
And then that's also you plunged
into that underworld space.
And that's also when you start to nurse
feelings of resentment and a grievement
and murder and homicide.
And even worse,
you know,
because if people are betrayed enough,
they start,
they start to obsess about the utility
of being itself and perhaps go to places
that no one would ever want to go if
they were in their right mind and to,
and to develop a nurse fantasies
of the ultimate revenge.
And that's a horrible place to be.
And that's held as far as I can tell.
And that's why hell is always
been a suburb of the underworld.
Because if,
if you get plunged into a situation that
you don't understand and things are not
good for you anymore,
it's one step from being
completely confused.
It's only one step from being completely
confused to being completely outraged
and resentful.
And then it's only one step from
there to really looking for revenge.
And that can take you
places that well that,
that merely to imagine
properly can be traumatic.
And I've seen that happen
with people many times.
And I think that anybody who uses their
imagination on themselves can see how
that happens because I don't imagine
there's a single person in the room that
hasn't nursed fairly intense
fantasies of revenge,
at least at one point in their life.
And usually,
you know,
for what appear to be good reasons,
it's no picnic to get betrayed.
That's for sure.
That can shake your faith in being,
but if it shakes it so badly that
you turn against being itself,
that certainly no solution,
that's for sure.
All it does is make everything that's bad.
Even worse.